the next speaker where is he is john
what's your what's your current title
john what's your job title
energy projects manager for the greater
southeast energy hub got it right
uh and john uh has previously worked
with suffolk climate change partnership
yeah anybody else i should mention
is that good enough so john
from my perspective john is the go-to
energy man
particularly on renewables so i follow
him on twitter
and every day
he he his amazing amount of information
coming from john so he really knows his
stuff absolutely so you know he's the
man i would turn to i did yesterday and
he gave me some factoids for today so
much appreciated john so john
over to you thank you very much
all right thank you very much ian um
yeah thank you for inviting me to speak
here this morning um it's great to be
back in in suffolk
speaking um to you today
i live in suffolk still i live just
north of ipswich and yeah i did spend
nearly 10 years working with babe mid
suffolk through the suffolk climate
change partnership as a community
advisor so a few familiar faces in the
room and um yeah work on community
buildings and parishes um
over that time period i now work for a
team called the greater south east
energy hub it's actually quite similar
job just
broader geography we're funded by the
government to work with local
authorities and communities to
accelerate the delivery of local energy
projects um
of all shapes and sizes and i'll be
talking specifically about the support
we offer for communities through that
um i was just thinking
um when phil had his slides up about the
net zero plans through to 2050 how
much time is that really and i was
thinking back well how 2050 is 30 years
in the future what was 30 years ago and
it's well there's a big event i can
remember from back then 1990 was that
penalty shootout in the world cup final
so actually now yeah gaza crying and all
that that's further away in time than
2050 so just to kind of put it in some
perspective that's
how much time we've now got it's time to
get on and start planning
okay
so i thought i'd just start off just by
showing this um
demonstration here i've pulled out some
data about where are we using fossil
fuels at the moment in weber and
mid-suffolk and i've got the data here
for baber
so you can see
obviously being a rural area people need
to drive transport fuel makes quite a
big chunk of our energy use still
so yeah petrol is actually
you can see the charts there the blue
line on that top graph is 2005 and the
orange line is 2018
so you can actually see petrol use has
actually risen slightly over that time
period in baber
gas use drops slightly electricity drops
slightly as well as heating oil but
those are the four prominent uses and
fossil fuels there you'll notice coals
on there we don't actually use very much
coal in the uk anymore a few barbecues
but not like we used to with power
stations and everything so that's been
the big progress over that time period
um we've made some really big changes in
the electricity sector getting coal off
the system through renewables and gas
and you can see their carbon emissions
has dropped about 25 percent since 2005
to 2018
and life doesn't feel too much different
um in terms of
back then to now so we can make some
pretty hefty
um cuts in our carbon emissions without
too much difficulty
but yeah that achievement in the carbon
reduction has primarily come through the
energy electricity sector
um
and in terms of local energy um
previously yeah getting coal off that
was the domain of people who ran power
stations the offshore wind farms it was
quite a discreet group of people that
made that change happen
whereas the next big phase of
decarbonisation that
has to evolve as a council of families
said earlier everyone in this room is
what
we use to heat our homes
and how we drive it's going to get quite
personal so whereas
the first phase of decarbonisation was a
small group of people the next phase has
to involve everybody
so as community leaders um yeah we need
to start engaging our neighbours and our
communities and start planning how we're
going to shift these
chunks of energy away from petrol and
oil and gas
onto clean energy like electricity
so phil set up it really nicely um
community owned renewable energy is what
we'll be talking about now
the government's plans that were
announced this week really set in stone
the kind of overall strategy for the
country
which is really to generate as much
low-carbon electricity as we possibly
can through renewables and nuclear and
other sources
um to then use that power to then
decarbonize other sectors like heating
and transport so the first thing to do
is see what opportunities we have to
generate electricity locally
this picture here some of you may
recognize it this is actually nail and
school
here in baber
and this was in fact the uk's first
community-owned um solar energy project
that's quite an accolade i think um so
back in 2011 when the feeding tariff was
first introduced group of parents that
were associated with the school
recognized it had a great rooftop for
solar energy
so they clubbed together they formed a
village energy cooperative they
approached the school and the county
council say well can we fund a solar
array on the school and give the
electricity for free
to the school and that's how it happened
a group of about 20 households in
neyland
um all co-invested in this solar energy
ray and got it installed on the school
and in fact that instigated the council
once they saw the opportunity with solar
energy they then did their own internal
program which saw another 90 schools in
the county
follow through with solar installations
that was instigated i would say by this
one in neyland so it shows the power of
community lead showing the initiative
and have the ripple effect it can have
on other parties
and i think that's also got a biomass
foil of that school as well
so at the greater south east energy hub
we run something called the rural
community energy fund
which is a government-funded grant
scheme which is there for parish
councils town councils and community
energy groups
um to get some extra resources
um to engage like a lot of them are
probably going to be volunteers doing it
in their spare time and some of these
projects can be quite complex
so our grant fund enables you to draw in
professional consultancy support
we offer initially a stage one
feasibility grants so you can engage
professional energy consultants
solicitors and all that
who will do the kind of technical
analysis of what renewables are suitable
for your parish or your location
they'll advise you on
the sort of appropriate legal structure
to set up like a community benefit
society or a community interest company
and they'll do the work in working out
can what's the grid connections like
what sort of planning permission do you
need to proceed
that can then be followed up with a
stage two development grant where we can
provide further funding to help you do
more detailed studies
like if you're doing a solar farm you
might need to look at the ecology or the
flooding situation that sort of thing
um but yeah we're there to get you to
the point where you can start to finance
that project through a community share
offer or getting some ethical investment
for a project
so a few case studies of how we've used
that funding to date we've now allocated
over a million pounds um through that
fund across the whole southeast of
england
and this is one project i really like
which is a solar farm in berkshire
i don't know if you're familiar with the
term a fuel allotment charity um it's
something that exists in a few
parishes
and they're actually quite historic the
fuel allotment charity was um
they were set up at the time of
enclosures
so
um when
common land was enclosed a bit of land
was often re kept back for the parish to
use they literally use it as a fuel
allotment they would grow trees on it
and other crops which they would harvest
every year and they would distribute
that wood fuel to the poor of the
village
and this is a fuel allotment charity in
berkshire still owned that land from
several hundred years ago and they'd
used it for other purposes but still
with that charitable mission to bring in
income to
offer a local benefit
but we've actually given them some grant
money to see can they use that land now
to put a solar farm up
so rather than growing trees they're now
going to use that sunlight to generate
renewable electricity sell it to the
grid sell it to local customers
and they're going to use the profits
they make from that renewable energy to
then yeah keep their original charitable
purpose going they'll use it to support
the fuel poor of their village
so they've got 20 acres of land they
don't need all of that they're going to
use about two hectares of it for a solar
farm so still plenty of space for
greenery and wildlife
yeah so
at the moment they've got stage one
funding
and yeah we're currently working with a
few organizations to see if they can get
some bridge finance to bring
construction and talk to people about
getting a power purchase agreement to
buy the electricity
um yeah the comment was made earlier
about
yeah if we're going to see a lot of
these
that community benefit that phil talked
about
yeah the government's plan is for to
have carbon free electricity in the uk
by 2035 so that is going to mean a lot
more renewable energy
um a lot of wind power but also more
solar power
so there's plenty of opportunity still
for more power on rooftops but we will
see more solar farms come forward in
fields and our landscapes
so i think it's really crucial for
communities to be involved in that
process and actually to share ownership
of these infrastructure projects that
they'll be living with and you can
actually see once you do have that
community involvement and ownership
all the profits that come from that
solar farm can be retained locally to
subsidise other local services
so
some
some communities chose to use their
surplus to support food banks during the
covered crisis
others are looking to fund rural bus
services and electric buses
um and it's also just a good way for
people to invest their savings and
pensions um to see it being good puts
good use for the next generation
so yeah community solar farms is
something we're keen to support going
forward
um the other c um
area we've been supporting is renewable
heating
so this is a project you may have heard
of it's got quite a bit of press
they're building it at the moment and
villager swath and prior just over the
border in cambridge here near new
markets
they've actually a village quite common
at
baber amid suffer ones they're off the
gas grid they're on heating oil and lpg
and electric
and so the parish council there and
they'd done a project where they'd got a
community land trust to build some
social housing
and then they thought well can we use
this kind of community building approach
in other areas and they looked at this
question how can we get the whole
village off heating oil
so that again they use the rural
community energy fund to do a study of
how they could
set up a village heating network
um so you can see a map of it there and
there's a field just on the edge of the
village where they're going to build an
energy center which will incorporate
boreholes for ground source heat pumps
there'll be an air source heat pump
there and a solar farm connecting into
it to provide power and heat
to supplement and the costs
and then
they're gonna they're currently building
um a heat main for the village so from
that energy center
insulated heating pipes will run down
the street and each house will then be
able to connect into it
using some kind of interface unit so
they'll get rid of their oil tanks
they'll get rid of their boilers
and they'll be able to interface with
this
communal heat supply um and it's been
designed to be a very um similar cost to
what people were paying for their oil
anyway
um and i think yeah if you've had to
order oil recently you can it's gone up
the same as gas has so
um doing it this way you're insulating
your community from those kind of
volatile
price hikes as well
um another version of that renewable
heating
we've also seen projects that are
looking to supply heat to a single large
energy user
so this is a project we supported in the
thames valley
just west of london so maidenhead energy
group
you can see the river thames is just
running through the picture at the back
there this is a leisure center that's
just next to the river
and we gave them some funding to see
could that use the river thames as a
heat source to supply heat via heat pump
to the leisure center they've ended up
actually going through a ground source
heat pump because i think there are
roads and other things in the way
but similar premise the community group
will own and operate the heat pump and
will have a heat supply contract with
the leisure center so
the leisure centre hasn't had to do
any of the work themselves or find the
money to build it so they're partnered
with the community energy group
they're going to raise their finance
like naylan did with people from the
area i think they've just raised about
150 200 000 pounds to build towns
and again yes an example of how people
can club together to solve a energy
issue
um for a community facility like this
um and
another variation of renewable heating
um
yeah so if we are going to be talking
about phasing gas boilers out by 2035
they're actually also talking about
phasing fossil fuel heating and off gas
grid areas sooner
because oil and lpg are more carbon
intensive fuels so there was a
consultation launch this week where
they're going to look at phasing out oil
and gas oil and lpg by actually by 2026
for new sales
so
helping rural communities understand
their options for domestic heating is
going to be really important over the
next few years and certainly recommend
using some of the grant funds that are
coming out like there and there's going
to be a home upgrade scheme a home
upgrade grant which will be available
for fuel poor households in off gas grid
areas to get insulation and heating
systems some other people in our team
will be managing that
but there could also be community
approaches to individual heat pumps as
well
so we've worked with a few villages to i
know in suffolk's running a solar
together bulk by scheme at the moment so
could a similar proposed premise operate
for domestic heat pumps
um
a few years ago when i was working in
suffolk we ran a trial project with
cookley and walpole parish council where
we worked with a few
heat pump and biomass boiler installers
say if we can guarantee you 10 15
installs in this village this heating
season
um can you offer us a discount
and through that kind of
yeah community scale
organization
um
the
installers offered a 15 discount off
their normal installation prices as if
it had been a one-off
um so yeah we're very keen to see if
there's other ways of
yeah pooling that community level um
support and education to help
rural householders make this transition
from what they're used to to other forms
of heat pumps
um i think that's the main
thing as my contact details and there if
you want to get in touch i'll be around
for the panel session earlier
um but yeah i just really want to
emphasize that point that yeah this next
phase really has to be well every parish
is going to have to have their own plan
and action so hopefully see a wave of
action sweep up the river star and up
the a140 and we're here to help
thank you
you